you've seen the code vein teaser now  prepare to dine on a whole bunch of new  details I'm Tony and this is your  vampiric gamespot news update  bandai namco has released a ton of new  screenshots and information about its  upcoming third-person action RPG we can  see a bunch of armored up vampires giant  monsters and a variety of environments  your character known as a revenant can  increase their powers called gifts by  draining the blood from your enemies  you know vampire stuff this blood can  raise your strengths weaken enemies and  even attach new abilities to your  weapons code vein is developed by the  team behind God Eater and published by  Bandai Namco the same force behind the  smash-hit Dark Souls games it's coming  to quote major home consoles in 2018 be  sure to subscribe to be the first to  know exactly what platforms they're  talking about there and for some less  violent action check out our Mario Kart  8 - luxe gameplay  you  [Music]